what is happening there citizens of
the reject Nation we are gonna watch
from new rock stars today when King the exact
moment when King when King killed Thanos yeah
we're gonna react to this today hey John how
are you how are you I'm good how are you sir
um I want to know how you're doing beforehand
I'm doing good you can hear it in my voice
I've been just excited to keep listening to
this baritone of yours see now it's just stuffy
alrighty John just shot a reaction Dumb and
Dumber keep looking for that oh teasing for
the future what you don't need to talk about
my biceps John but you can't talk about my new
t-shirt John please plug in the shirt the shirt
who influences the influencers Rorschach inspired
in one of my personal faves it's my Twitter bio
and now it's a shirt they finally succeeded come
full circle your Twitter bio is legit yeah screw
influencers am I right screw them all all of them
who influences them it's a shopster edition.com go
go get it yeah real rejects leave a like all right
and quantumania will open Marvel phase five
with Kang the Conqueror as the vast Cult of
Warring Champions that the Avengers have to face
but given Ken's champ status does it logically
follow that he must have killed Thanos at some
point or at many points Jurassic crew are now
specifically pitting Thanos versus gang and when
you go back to re-watch Loki and Multiverse of
Madness Infinity war end game you can actually
pinpoint these specific Nexus moment when Kang
would have targeted the Mad Titan and I'm gonna
break down oh interestingly assassination tells
us about the surprising status of the 616 universe
as we know it you know if they have just one line
in there about you know if they talk about Thanos
if ant-man's like gloating about how they you know
him in the Avengers they they took on Thanos and
then he just has some throwaway line about like oh
yeah I've killed a bunches I've killed 20 Thanos
like 20 to 30 Thanos I have a necklace of Thanos
ears little chambers that would just make him
seem so badass and be an ultimate ultimate there
it's a quick way to communicate to the audience
that he is a worse threat than that just do a
cutaway where it's just like that episode of The
Walking Dead with Glenn and Negan just do that
there's a montage you know me bashing his head in
yeah yeah it's cut to that joke was not clear that
joke could have been clear it could have been
clear in an interview at Brazilian Comic-Con
earlier this month Quantum Main IA director Peyton
Reed unprovoked compared Kang to Thanos we're uh
encountering an antagonist who's unlike anything
they've ever experienced and that includes Thanos
and notice right at the end of that line Peyton
Reed fist bumps Kang actor Jonathan majors in this
interview but was later asked about his workout
regimen and how physical he would be getting as
Kang and we want to know if you're going to use
any of these workouts you had to do with your
bite on this next movie all of it all of it all of
it like Hulk no I'm kidding it's funny because if
you read Dynasty Kank he doesn't fight it's not
like a brawl guy yeah is that going to happen
here you're going to get all of it get all of it
that's cool that's cool King's gonna do backflips
that's right confirmed push-ups he's gonna do
one-handed push-ups with his pinkies yeah I can
travel through time but have you seen me travel
through the air oh able to leave tall buildings
at a single bound wow that's right man he's
gonna jump on a skateboard it's gonna be crazy
all gangs every iteration you're gonna get all
of it I clearly want to be here and I'm not just
doing this so I won't get fined I don't know maybe
Major's just had trouble hearing the interviewers
it was really loud in that room but he is or
he's racist as discussed in other interviews the
wide range of characterizations he would get to
create SK as the primary thing that Drew him to
this role and while Peyton Reed has described
this quantumania Kang as a variant who conserves
of energy with Majors saying all of it and his
fist bump with the director the mention of him
being more fearsome than Thanos I think Majors is
gonna play at least one Kang who makes Thanos say
just that for a drop of blood oh [__] remember
in the quantumania trailer for the show we've seen
so far Ken has implied he has killed countless
Avengers in the past and we know for sure ever
seen someone read so much into a fist bump I
know oh it says everything which Thanos was a
major antagonist and Anna showed up in Loki
episode two in the multiple choice question
on Miss minutes training module Thanos has two
apples he eats both the realizes he wants more
he goes back in time 20 minutes and eats the
apples again does this mean the apples will
not have existed in the timeline he left hey
no because time is constantly happening B the
question doesn't matter because the branch cannot
change another dedication to the voice would have
been hungry prior because the grandfather Paradox
already accounted for the change of matter before
it's moved when we look back at this the TVA
Rank and files seem to suggest B was a correct
answer but I don't know by the Loki season one
finale we go see your answer seems actually look
whatever your thoughts on this anyone who thinks
that they firmly understand 100 the logic of Loki
season one and what exactly happened in that
finale they don't even understand it which is
why I am actually revisiting it currently for a
major project that I am working on announcement
or about this Kang period he remains is that he
made an exception for The Avengers to use time
travel he remains wanted the 616 Avengers to
defeat Thanos using the Time Heist when Slayer
confirmed this to Loki in episode one we're
not here to talk about the Avengers oh no no
what they did was supposed to happen you you
escaping was not now I have theorized before
that he remains made that exception so that Tony
Stark would later unlock Quantum time travel with
that inverted Mobius strip in his basement this
being the discovery that Nathan Richards would
later build on and master a thousand years
later and that he who remained scripted this
out so that Stark would die shortly after so
that he would have no time to dismantle that
technology or you know bird in the ocean like
he likes to do with this town I really hope
they confirmed that MCU the more it starts to
seem like it's less of a sacred timeline but
really an exception to the multiversal norm
616 is like a rogue timeline it's a variant
branch that went unprooned the normal Marvel
universe is probably supposed to have mutants
alongside Avengers right but surely to prune
all other Kang Rivals during that multiversal
war that he talked about in the finale he left
one 616 timeline untouched so that it would keep
his own origin intact basically a massive Kang
tree he remains clipped all other branches so
other carrying apples fell down to the ground
then only one branch remaining that left to
the heat remains [__] too high enough off the
ground so hungry hungry Thanos could need that
Apple that kind of makes metaphors there but I
hope it made sense but as a better example okay
first had no Tony Stark present currently but it
was still a universe where he once existed based
on those Ultron sentries yes with an Illuminati
formed by Stephen Strange who had led them to
defeat Thanos in their Infinity War how by dream
walking with the dark holes now we don't often
discuss the past possession of the dark holes and
who handed it off to whom something I suspect that
we will learn more about in Phase 5 with titles
like Agatha the coven of chaos but I think The
a38 Illuminati's win over Thanos was scripted for
them by Kang Kang had curated their timeline so
that a38 strange would use the dark hole to defeat
Thanos now why do we think Kang was involved with
this I mean I thought King was involved with all
of it yeah I thought he wrote Every timeline so
just every timeline must have a Thanos portion
but everyone's plot line is has been scripted by
King isn't that what Loki was establishing Beyond
Thanos introduce with every video every character
yeah it has to be every single character this is
like every single character right if you weren't
in the script Ant-Man that's why he's not killed
you yeah and killed the Quicksilver yeah I feel
like you can do that with any character killed
everyone am I missing something no I I I think
you're right I don't know he seems to be in
control of everyone's fate and if you step
out of line they're gonna come find you so I'm not
like dogging on your video or anything like that
wait what is the I thought there was going to be
something a little bit let's find out maybe he'll
maybe I'll have an answer well two major clues
in this crime scene first the Gauntlet that Ted
Thanos has acquired 4 out of six Infinity Stones
he's got the power the space reality and the Soul
stones but not the Mind Stone and not the time
Stone so this Thanos must have been killed right
before he would have acquired the time Stone
secondly it's the way this Thanos was clearly
killed his own sword plunged into his chest now we
don't know which of these Illuminati had delivered
the death blow but given the fact that this
is a corporeal wound and not like him blasted
to Smithereens by Blackpool or something I'm
going to assume that this was some kind of combo
three Richard slingshoting that sword using his
elastic body I think that because reads elastic
slingshot Maneuvers are really the one physical
Edge he has over his opponents it's one range
attack that Thanos wouldn't have seen coming with
that mailbox is a death blow that needed Kang's
patriarchal ancestor to be in the mix that's why
I think Multiverse of Madness made sure to include
that line about Reed Richards having children
Reed Richards is a distant ancestor to Nathaniel
Richards Kane so in the a38 universe Kang did this
so that these Marvel heroes would have no name
to have to invent time travel to undo famous ah
you were gay yeah okay this is the one time travel
timeline yeah same art our timeline yeah 616. I
call that our timeline that's where we live in
here that's right but yeah the main one that we
follow is the only one that was allowed to have
time travel maybe what I think Mr Voss is alluding
to there had to be a special kind of variation
perhaps for every way that Thanos died like he
doesn't die the exact same way every one of them
sure you know yeah and so this one variation
had to leave the necessity for time travel and
the rest of them just had to be like ah here's a
Nifty you know way to do this so that uh yeah they
can stay contained to your own little timeline or
people are yelling at us in the comments right now
why don't you there's fake fans he's limited these
Heroes to multiversal travel by dreamwalking from
the dark old sorcery not technological Quantum
time travel that Kang would use in the future
they use magic not science so that Kang and only
magic is science waiting to be discovered whatever
sloppy incursions their magic caused so this
right here at this moment that Kang engineered
thanos's death right before the time Stone would
enter the play and snuffing out a future in-game
Time Heist which makes sense because this
battle of Titan was conqueror Thanos at his
most vulnerable and likely was a Nexus moment
for Thanos to be assassinated in any timeline
that's why it makes sense to blame Peter Quill
for punching Thanos out of his trance in Infinity
War as one moment The Avengers could have taken
Thanos down before the snap happened we're right
and it needed to be part of this overall dog pile
because when you re-watch infinity War he totally
provided essential distractions for other Avengers
to be able to pin Thanos but really they were so
close to ending the 616 Infinity War all that Kang
would have had to do to change the odds here would
be to add someone like oh I don't know Ant-Man
Ant-Man could have snuck inside the gauntlet and
wriggled it off the hand he could have got
it or the bum hole the bum give him a heart
attack he could blown his butt out any number of
hypothetical what ifsc right and for Kang to be a
true conqueror Thanos must just be a villain from
an older age that merely played a part in Kang's
machinations and died at a deliberate moment of
Kang's choosing for most realities that moment was
definitely on Titan except in 616 when Kang needed
Thanos to get far enough for the Avengers to start
putting the word Quantum in front of everything
I get it okay so every timeline he's supposed
to die on Titan yes and it would have happened on
our timeline again ours we own 616. it would have
happened on our timeline if Peter Quill hadn't
gone to mess things up damn Earth dweller quill
that's why yeah okay got it yeah it's all his
fault but he was saying that he he allowed that to
happen Kang so that way Tony could create that'll
yeah that's okay right so Peter needed to do that
that's right yeah Kevin wrote a weird detail
where he's like Peter's gonna help help distract
Thanos so the Defenders can get the drop but then
he's also going to break him out of the trance so
then the time travel will have to be a quantity oh
that is a fascinating Theory and that also saves
you from the weirdness of the writing of Peter
doing no that's actually a really cool theory yes
we were finally understood what we were
watching at the very end of the video it
is actually a really cool Theory welcome
to a real reaction to this yes yeah yeah
this is Grime to new Rockstar subscribe to
real rejects leave a like pick yourself up
who influences the influencers how can you
call us influencers who do you think we're
influencing at this moment yeah you
to get a shirt let's send this to them
Chris wamov Chris is known as one of the nicest
guys at our patreon page but I'd like to think
that if I was traveling the Multiverse you'd
find out that only on our Earth is he a nice
guy that every other Earth he is some kind of
Destroyer real just a nihilistic son of a beast
going around ruining people's I'm not saying he's
like a violent you know shopraved evil person he's
not like you know the newest people or something
but he's just very frustrating to be around you
know like he is human talks about himself
he never has to any questions very dramatic
like he's very drawn just Petty when someone's
opening up about themselves make it about himself
energy vampire noise fortunately on our Earth
on to back to the Earth our Earth 616. It Was
Written in the Kang script I was listening you
can't blame me because it's part of improv
that's right and you can and then Kang wrote
the John listen I'm saying that on our
Earth we got the good one I forgot what
I was going I got so distracted this is the
best Chris I hope you have a Happy New Year